hey little guys my name is achernar and
welcome to a little update video
regarding let him dare 36 so I'm not
actually gonna do it
III didn't want to like I didn't want to
prolong my denial of a lot of their 36
too long because otherwise you might get
excited unfortunately I don't have time
to do it this this this weekend however
the reason I made a whole video just to
say unfortunately I won't be doing it is
because I will be doing something
exciting next weekend right so I thought
that I was actually really looking
forward to doing a lot of their 36
because it's been a while I mean I don't
think I did let him do a 35 no I
wouldn't have in fact and you can see
how live these videos are I'm googling
stuff right now I think the last time
that I did according to my alarm day
page was 34 yeah I believe that was what
December last year yeah that would have
been December last year and I made the
game growth and I was actually really
looking forward to having time to
actually make a project right I wanted
to have time I wanted to have this
entire weekend where I could actually
spend making a project like so to speak
working on my own work right doing
something for myself because I really
haven't had too much time to just write
code and program on my own stuff so I
was really really looking forward to
doing that and unfortunately it's I
didn't didn't work out because I've had
I have stuff to do so it's very
unfortunate but but to make up for that
because again I really wanted to work on
my own stuff and I really wanted to
actually spend some time live streaming
is I decided that next weekend I'm
actually free and next weekend what I'm
going to do is basically the whole
weekend almost I'm going to stream
myself basically porting Sparky to
Android okay so from start to finish
there'll be like basically a single live
stream however long it takes it may take
a long time right but however long it
takes I'm going to port Sparky to
Android so in case you're not familiar
what you see on the screen right now is
the Sparky Engine on the test 3d scene
which is just a very basic scene that
shows you basic kind of physically based
rendering
so this is what Sparky is it's a game
engine that I've been working on for for
quite some time now
I haven't actually worked on it lately
almost at all but nonetheless it is
something that I really want to kind of
get back to working on and I thought
that since I will actually need to use
Sparky for a few kind of research
projects that I'm doing and they are
specifically for mobile devices I
thought it'd be a great kind of weekend
- poor Sparky completely true Android
the reason I'm not doing iOS is because
first of all I don't really want to
spend $150 and on on developer account
and also because I need a Mac like I
would have to get my Mac out for that
and it might be a bit difficult to
stream that I mean I do have a MacBook
Pro but I'd have to like hook that up
with streaming and like I I don't know
it's just gonna be like even though it's
actually a lot more straightforward to
get iOS working with this just because
Objective C and Objective C for C++ is
really like you know I mean it
integrates much better with C++ in fact
if you're writing like objective C++
it's basically just you couldn't have
one line of code that's written in C++
and one line of code that's written in
Objective C it's beautiful right
however Android is a bit harder to set
up but honestly it's not that difficult
and I think I've never done anything
mobile on this channel before so I
thought that it would be a really cool
experience for you guys to see how to
basically take a C++ game engine written
in written for Windows right which
happens has bought both directx and
opengl and how to actually port that
onto a mobile platform and in this case
specifically onto Android because I know
that a lot of people a lot of you guys
have always been kind of using Java for
making games on Android and that's
that's okay but obviously in the kind of
the larger scale of things you do want
to be running native code and that also
means you can share the same codebase of
course between iOS and Android
but anyway getting away from all that
that's gonna happen next weekend so next
weekend I believe is the so the Saturday
will be on the 3rd of September was
September already that's crazy
I have to think I'm not doing anything
nokay that is free so the third of
September Australian Eastern Standard
Time it like probably nine o'clock in
the morning I'm actually going to get up
early for this so 9 a.m. Australian
Eastern Standard Time
next weekend on Saturday the 3rd of
September I will begin my live stream on
Twitch or TV 4 / the channel there'll be
a link in the description make sure you
follow me on Twitter twitter.com 4 / the
churner because I'll obviously be
keeping guys up to date there and I will
tweet out when I start streaming and
also if there are any problems with the
stream I always update my Twitter of
course with the status of that stream
and everything so you definitely wanna
be following me there but basically if
you're interested in that I'm gonna put
out some videos as well probably on the
channel archive channel but I'll see if
I can actually put some on the on this
channel right if I actually managed to
make this frame like high-quality and
offer everything I will definitely
definitely try and do that but anyway
that is the that is how the cookie
crumbles I always say that I don't know
why it's just the thing that comes to my
phrase it's just that just the phrase
that comes to my head at the end of
videos anyway that's the idea if you
like this decision of mine to do this
please hit a like button I mean like
it's it's definitely something that I
need to do anyway and I thought I might
as well stream it and I just thought you
know let's sit down do this Android
thing in one sitting kind of just get
this running already and and everything
will be good ok so that is the plan
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and I'll see you guys soon goodbye